buck and we're going to start the
subcommittee meeting subcommittee
meeting on House Bill 655.
so as a result of the hearing that we
had
this week it seemed that there was a
concern for the disciplinary portion of
the bill
is there anyone here that would like to
speak about something other than that
yes would you like to come to the
good morning I'm Elizabeth Robb I'm a
practicing licensed acupuncturist in
Manchester New Hampshire and as I was
reading through the bill I answered my
own questions from the other day but um
I noticed that a number of boards
um
it says that they'll receive a license
board is crossed out and it's replaced
with office but that's not the case with
the licensed acupuncturists and I was
hoping that we could just keep things
consistent if the naturopaths and the
mental health professionals and the
pharmacy interns are going to get their
applications reviewed by the office then
just put the acupuncturers licenses
applications under that also just keep
that's that makes sense to me does
anybody have any comments on that
no okay okay we'll put that in the
amendment
representative Pearson sent us written
testimony but if you'd like to speak for
a few minutes
thank you madam chair uh for the record
Mark Pearson among other things I chair
DHHS oversight committee
um and that's kind of the relevance of
why I'm here after the Boston globe's
Spotlight team
uh did a lengthy lengthy series of
articles about a surgeon practicing in
New Hampshire
it mentioned that there were 20
malpractice settlements against that
surgeon posted on the Board of Medicine
site in Massachusetts with zero On The
Board of Medicine site in New Hampshire
so I immediately cranked up a
subcommittee of
oversight to start looking into this
bringing together stakeholders from the
Board of Medicine the medical society
hospitals nurses in the various groups
oplc and with that in mind there's a few
things I wish to comment on in house
bill 655. first of all on page five
lines 10 to 14. it gives to oplc
some non-lapsing funds which will give
them the opportunity to move immediately
my subcommittee of oversight did not
find fault with the individual from the
Board of Medicine who is doing
investigations what we did find is this
was a retired individual working without
compensation very much part-time the
problem is not this gentleman the
problem is there were not enough of them
and if oplc at that point had monies
that they could use that could have been
rectified almost immediately absent that
we are still not doing the kind of work
we felt the subcommittees felt everybody
wanted to be done so that's Point number
one
uh points number two is it mentions in
the bill that
um the executive director of oplc will
be working up various protocols that
Board of Medicine will follow in the
various investigations this too is
something our subcommittee worked on and
in recent conversation with Lindsay
Courtney
um I believe she welcomes the
subcommittee's continued work in other
words let us work with her everyone
seems to be happy we've got this the
group together and together we can go
forward to make recommendations to her
for the board
and then my final Point
um
is Page 19.
[Music]
uh
uh and go down around verse yeah verse
line 22. and following and on to the
next page it speaks of requirements for
dentists using anesthesia
I read this over recently I was at the
Delta Dental event and had opportunity
to speak with a number of dentists and
it does not seem that what is in here is
necessarily wrong my question is should
it be in here
and why I say that is formally I chaired
the Health and Human Services Committee
of the house and whenever we had a bill
that told doctors how to practice
medicine we routinely unanimously it
yelled it because that is not the job of
the legislature is to put it into law
first of all Let The Board of Medicine
and the medical societies come up with
those protocols if there's egregious
mistakes we can deal with that but let
the professionals come up with it
secondly
Whenever there seems to be a change in
the law it is because there are new best
practices well what happens if two years
from now there's new best practices
again well we're stuck with this law
saying what best practices are
so rather than going through the whole
lengthy procedure of a bill to change
the best practices
it seems to my former committee that the
medical boards medical societies could
make those changes in protocols in other
words this may well be good stuff here
in the bill it just doesn't belong in
the bill regulation of medical groups
Dental groups should not be in
legislation to say exactly who should be
in the room at what point that should be
the job of the societies of
professionals so with that that's my
testimony this morning and thank you
thank you does anyone have any questions
and this is sort of an informal meeting
so anybody can
pop their hand up if they have a
question
nope okay thank you so thank you for
representative infantine
thank you
other than the disciplinary election I
have two questions on page 12.
line 10. it talks about that the um the
boards can enjoin
someone from doing something an
injunction without bond is available to
I'm so sorry can you it was Paige page
12 page 12 line 10. thank you
oh yes I see
so
um I have a lot of uh experience with
injunction bonds and I just didn't I'm
curious
um
I consider this the Executive Branch the
oplc
says the executive branch override the
judicial Branch's requirement to have
injunction Bond relief
so what happens is if I join you and I
tell you to stop doing something the
court will say well what happens it will
if you're wrong in requesting this
injunction against you
and it's going to I tell you you can't
sell your widget because it has a logo
that I think is mine so I am join you
for two months from selling your widget
and if I'm wrong
you've lost two months of Revenue I have
to post a bond equal to what we think
that or what the judge determines that
revenue is going to be and I end up
having to if I lose I end up having
caused you harm and I have to either pay
that amount or the bond will pay the
amount so I'm confused as to how a
junction without bond is available to to
the board
I think representative Courtney has an
answer for that so she could and um you
want to talk about okay you can point to
both of them at the same time the other
one and the other the other point I'd
like to make is line 20 through line I
36 this has to do with the oversight
committee
um I sit as a as a chairman of the labor
committee I sit on the Employment
Securities Advisory Board we meet
quarterly and we go over everything
that's going on with Employment
Securities
uh unemployment here in the state and it
is made up of two members of Labor uh
member of business uh one Senator one
representative and a few members of the
uh one member of the public and
a member of the Employment Securities
advisory or Employment Securities staff
having
three members of the house and two
members of the Senate I don't think
would be as effective as if you had
possibly one member from the oplc and
possibly two members whether you know
from one of the each of of two boards
um I think it gives you a better idea of
what's going on and you can hear from
all different sides it seems to be
effective Employment Securities Advisory
Board and
first of all trying to find two members
of the Senate good luck
so
those are my comments
representative I mean Miss Courtney can
you answer representative dad's question
and we'll make a note on the other
yes absolutely thank you
um
over the record in Lindsey Corner
executive director PLC with respect to
the bond that language is consistent
with language that exists in other
practice acts practically that that is
also how it works when the state seeks
to enjoin Behavior I can tell you from
my personal experience representing DHHS
at the Department of Justice we
regularly were able to seek and obtain
injunctions without a bond practically I
think the the reason for that is one the
state has immunity it's that private
parties don't have with respect to
um
loss recoveries and and secondly
requirement to put up a bond obviously
has an impact on funds state funds and
um so I think that those are really the
two policy bases uh for why
um State entities are not required to
put up a bond I don't I'm not taking a
position either way whether that should
be the case but I did just want to let
you know that that's pretty consistent
is there anyone else that wants to speak
about something other than disciplinary
action
okay
so then it's all about disciplinary
action right now
um does someone want to start the
conversation on that representative yes
please
thank you madam chair members of the
subcommittee my name is John dejoy and
I'm here today representing the National
Association of Social Workers the New
Hampshire chapter as well as the New
Hampshire Psychological Association
the the National Association of Social
Workers is requesting one addition that
is consistent with one of the
psychologists Edition as well and that
is in regard to the subject matter
experts relative to the investigations
we my client believes that subject
matter experts should always be of a
comparable licensure level and practice
background of the person that they're
investigating
we don't see that in the statute and
would request that that be added in
rulemaking
that is also a concern of the
psychologist but the psychologists have
a few other concerns that I'd like to
outline
relative to the some of the terms of
allegations and complaint
they are different from the terms that
folks are using today
or that folks are comfortable with and
the Practical implication of that is
when psychologists recertify or
re-license they have to acknowledge if
they have any current disciplinary
action or it's often called complaints
or investigations so our request would
be that regarding the terms of
allegations complaint investigation that
they be added to a definition section so
we're all understanding specifically
so you're asking for a definition of
allegation complaints and investigations
just so so that they can determine for
licensure and insurance purposes what
representative fuel has a question sorry
if that we
have that suggestion do you have uh
you have drafted a language that we
could put in I do not I could probably
model something together but I believe
director Courtney probably has more
specific language that she could share I
haven't I've talked to her I haven't
talked to her about this issue but I
would imagine she has language she could
relative to privacy and and my clients
testified regarding this the other day
there are concerns around privacy of
Records
in the current in the current RSA there
are clear protections of re-release of
of client records that are
retained as a result of Investigation
it it is unclear whether the language is
in the current bill and if it is we've
missed it and so let me give you a
practical explanation of what our
concern is I mean 91a is covered very
well that the records are maintained
relative to 91a
but as part of Investigation if I'm a
psychologist and records are received
the way the bill reads it is not clear
whether oplc could re-release those
records to another party
it is our belief that anytime client
records are used despite an
investigation they should never be
re-released to a third party
without proper court order to do so
so we would just like clarification that
the records that are maintained as part
of the investigation are not available
and the final request is that
the board of mental health and the board
of psychology currently have a different
disciplinary procedure than many of the
other boards
I'm sorry do they have similar
procedures and those two procedures okay
those two procedures are different the
social workers are quite comfortable
moving forward with the um the
procedures as outlined in the bill
before us
the psychologists are requesting to
maintain their existing disciplinary
procedure
now I can try to give you my best
understanding of what that looks like
ostensibly and I think there's other
people here who can probably explain it
better ostensibly it is a process within
the board where there are several
psychologists who are investigated or
investigators
um
there is a liaison between the board and
the oplc and investigators are assigned
by that liaison from within that pool of
of
um subject matter experts they provide
findings of of their investigation to
it's it's a little bit different because
it's a process within the board
structure as opposed to
um within oplc and working with the
board and that's the
and I believe that's what I have to
cover
okay Madam chair I apologize oh one last
the last thing that I would mention is
in in the the fines and and fees section
there is an uncapped potential for
um reimbursement for investigative costs
my clients believe that that should not
be in infinite it should have some cap
okay thank you
greetings I'm Dr Deborah Warner I'm
representing myself my practice Bright
Day psychology in Littleton New
Hampshire and I've also well informed
about the statutes I was part of the
process developing the psychology and
the some other Provisions that are in
both psychology and board of mental
health practice statutes
I presented you with a copy I'm sorry I
didn't get it over to you of a suggested
Amendment to the bill and it does
reference that it could be we could
rewrite section 22 of our chapter I can
give you copies of that as well it's a
bit longer but excuse me can you make
sure do you have extra copies there
I have
could you please give a copy to
um Mrs Miss Courtney behind you
from oplc
and also give a copy to representative
I'll give her my copy if you can give me
uh so uh I would suggest that for the
psychology uh statute that we make some
changes in the first section that gives
exceptions for override by the chapter
pertaining to a receipt of an allegation
investigation of a complaint
and that's in the first part of my
handout the next section section 144 is
about criminal records check that we
would have if there is if somebody does
not clear their criminal record check
that that should go before the board
it's section 145
that the board is the entity issuing the
license and not the office and certainly
they would delegate many many things to
the office to do
for automated licenses and such
um and in in Roman 2 of that same
section uh examinations they was crossed
out
written oral or both uh that it would be
retained sometimes when the candidate
the applicant fails one of the tests uh
they might go through a rewrite but the
board does give them another chance by
coming in to do an oral and very often
they pass I have a question so you're
speaking only for yourself I'm speaking
only for myself okay thank you
yes
um
missing from the
329b section 15 same at the top of the
next page you can see uh they need to
add a Roman 3 has passed the criteria
set forth by the board in its rules
somehow rather that's not in there in
the law but it is certainly in the rules
for the board of psychology
and then we get to section 147 where
there's a whole slew of repeals of the
psychology sections and
um you can see on my
lots of red in there
um we do not but I do not believe in
others I have conferred with uh do not
and you have heard Dr Phillips yes the
other day as well
um that we should not
repeal the rules making of the board
concerning license procedures or
relative to rules regarding complaint
procedures that those should remain in
the board and they do get help with oplc
it's usually very collaborative in that
way
um it's all right to just repeal the
establishment of fees
um I would not see that it's
advantageous to
um repeal the telepaths license that is
a very particular license that's not
covered under the new licenses offered
by this statute the the changes in this
bill the Talia medicine is an out of
state entry that is very easy it's
instantly
um
but it
granted you can do it online it as
designed it's not yet up and running but
somebody if they want to follow a
patient into the state who's traveling
one of our snowbirds or is a college
student that they could be done very
very easily and it's an ongoing license
it's not just 120 days the current
easier one is 120 days and it terminates
with a application for a full license
many people from other states don't want
um relative to injunction that's fine to
repeal in my opinion
when it comes to RSB 329b20 relative to
Temporary and emergency
um the the new statutes and as well as
this bill do provide for temp licenses
but they do not deal with the special
thing that we have in our practice our
specialty is forensic psychologists who
come in from other states to do
examinations and consultations with the
courts those can last longer than 120
days and they are often done in
sporadically throughout maybe even a
two-year period and the language that I
put in here would pull from the current
statute and keep just the forensic temp
license in place that was created
because there was much petition
we don't need the history we just want
your basic comments there you go
um
the
329 B21 relatively disciplinary action I
would omit that repeal
and then you go to section 22
investigations and complaints I did I
wouldn't repeal it but I would also
rewrite it I've got a longer version of
how I would write it bringing in the
language and the wording that goes with
what's been put forth in the oplc plan I
just must say that I am in favor of
getting this all together and having a
more coordinated fashion but these are
little things that need to go and so
that's it for my my recommendations for
my Amendment thank you so much we'll
take those into consideration there'll
be another follow-up meeting to this so
oh we are okay yeah I did have a couple
of clarifications of some things that
were said earlier should I go in those
let's wait on that quickly yes I'd like
to get to the meat of the matter today
okay
yes
um the gentleman with the red tie whose
good morning good morning my name is
James bommersbach I am the legislative
chair for the New Hampshire
Psychological Association uh just I
wanted to add a comment in addition to
Dr Warner's testimony uh it's my
understanding that our Psychological
Association which represents
approximately 200 psychologists in the
state is also in favor of retaining
language that would allow oral
examinations as part of the licensing
examination we are aware that the
current licensing procedures are
extensive and and could be beneficial to
change and I'm happy to have my
organization consult with Miss Courtney
about making changes to those but the
maintaining the oral examinations as
part of that is important because it
allows for an opportunity for someone to
on a rare basis not not I don't think
it's used that often but on our basis to
allow them to
demonstrate their skills in a way that
may not be they may be more favorable or
in their interest
um so even just a matter of making sure
that someone with a learning disability
who has difficulty with that kind of
essay test or multiple choice tests
allowing them to demonstrate their
skills in an alternative way again this
we don't think this happens very often
but it would be important not to prevent
it from happening
thank you very much thank you
it was really good for me to sit here
for an hour in the first hearing because
I got to hear from some of the other
boards
and my comments are going to be similar
to what I stated
last week with a few excuse me earlier
this week with some caveats I fully
respect
the the job that the oplc is trying to
do to organize
there was a lot of things all over the
place
I still think there are three different
groupings there are construction there
are professional and there are health
related organizations boards and some of
them need to be treated differently and
let me explain regarding the hearings
because my issues obviously like
everybody else a page 20 for the
electricians lines 13 through 21
repealing them some of these things
while I'm in favor of making some
changes that'll be good for the boards
and the oplc I'm not in favor of
repealing them
whole in one Lock Stock Barrel
we had a hearing the other day
we had a hearings officer we had an
attorney in the room
it was fantastic
the hearings officer could swear people
in they kept the conversation going when
someone went run on question you know
get to the question and it kept things
going well and I know that with the
attorney there with the hearings officer
there there was a protocol
and if anyone ever complained about what
went on there was a clear delineation of
exactly what happened who did what and
when
we the members electricians boards could
also ask questions
and of of the the witness if you will
and so we could ask questions we can
make decisions I feel the oplc wants to
make it so we're just the jury we have
to sit quietly we don't ask questions
and then they have a professional that
is going to
in essence question uh the witness or
the person that may be in trouble with
the board
um I don't want it to go that way now
that may work you heard someone state
that we don't have an expert I don't
know what that Clinical Psychology thing
person does so we need an expert to come
in so that would make sense in that case
but not all the boards I don't think the
um
Funeral Directors need another
professional funeral director nor the
electricians need another professional
electrician
in the room to ask the witness questions
so we can then be the jury
that may work in some other but I don't
believe it does for all
so
I'm in favor of the rule changes I'd
like them to be the protocol that the
oplc wants to use but I don't want some
of these repeals repeal it repealing the
fees
uh the board should clearly and I I I'll
be honest with you I was going to do it
but I've been up here four times this
week I have not studied 319c 6 9 and 12
probably as well as I should
um we won't hold it against you thank
you
um but you know there are some things in
there about the fees that that we would
like still have some authority to do
some of the disciplinary actions some of
the renewals some of the you know we
would like still like to be engaged and
have a say in some of these things
but we are okay with the oplc having
clear Direction and uniformity to many
of the things we do
but again it can't go overboard we don't
need an expert on electric in front of
three
three Master electricians
um so
I can't give you line by line Madam
chairman what needs to be done
um but I would I would rather
you know I like Maize a lot better than
I like shells
in law when it comes to the executive
branch and I hope
maybe if you're gonna have one more
meeting I can give you line by line what
things I'm okay with repealing in each
one of three six three nineteen C 6 12
and 14 and which ones I don't but I just
hope you understand what the difference
between what I feel the oplc wants to do
across the board
um that may be okay for some
but not all and I think it would be a
waste of time and money in certain
instances Plus
it makes us really mostly ineffective so
I think someone who testified before us
made a comment that there's the
efficiency and cost effectiveness of
doing it one way and Justice the other
it's a situation where we want balance
right that's right and so maybe
we are going to have another
subcommittee meeting on this because
this is quite
there's a lot there's a lot to this
and I'll take your recommendation
to heart as to the different
classifications of
of a boards because it seems to be
there are some boards that are stronger
than others
so I'll we'll let you know when the next
committee meeting and what you said
makes sense to me thank you and I and I
understand
their needs you know what what the the
oplc the commissioner wants to do I I in
my heart I do maybe it's a little bit of
an old-fashioned you know guy who wants
to move either slower or doesn't want
some of my authority taken away and and
um where we have to kind of strike that
balance but
as a legislator as a citizen I realize
we have to have some uniformity we
cannot expose the state
to uh
possible Financial you know detriment
because it's all over the place
correct or the public safety right yes
so thank you so much I think it's very
concise testimony
yes representative Miss Courtney now
she's going to be representative
oh wait I can't use that term
um
take the opportunity and I have um our
general counsel here to address uh some
of the concerns series because I I share
the same goal particularly of the ones
that articulated by representative
infantine I would suggest so what this
statute does is it it's it's a little
scary because it repeals a lot of
sections but it repeals a lot of
sections that are similar and puts it
somewhere else
just globally we have
um if you put all of our
statutes in one
one document thank you Doug sorry I'm a
little tired today so over 800 pages
long labor which is a similar agency has
less than 25 percent of that and our
statutes all say pretty much the same
thing but in slightly different ways so
what we'd like to see happen is have one
statute regarding procedures and one
statute regarding licensing as opposed
to having to look at 50s plus different
statutes it's an administrative
nightmare
so from a policy standpoint we are
certainly open to having
um you know amending the language to be
different as to how hearings and
disciplinary proceedings must be run but
we we do think it's necessary to
basically
strip a lot of these similar statutory
Provisions out of the statute so that we
can provide the best support possible
regarding the hearings the
it is referenced in 310 the proposed
Bill provides for a procedure that it's
very similar to how it's run now
I didn't see anything in the language
that would eliminate a board's ability
to ask questions and we would expect
that that would continue to occur
because they are the subject matter
experts I think certainly that language
could be firmed up to make that clearer
and we would welcome that change but we
we I guess feel pretty strongly that
we'd like to have a little bit more of a
concise statute for us to look at
because it's very it's just very
challenging for us to administer
um
and Doug I'll let you weigh in on the
other stuff because I could go on for
representative shuitt has a question
thank you
um
hi Miss Courtney uh you said that
uh of the repeals some of the things
that still need to be in place are put
in other places is it possible for you
to give us
I don't know a diagram this is repealed
but it's foot here
yes we can certainly do a crosswalk for
you and bring it to the next meeting or
hopefully in advance of the next meeting
if that would be helpful
um because the statute is I mean the
bill is huge but there are really only a
couple of things that it does which is
sets forth a streamlined process for
investigations streamline process for
disciplinary hearings and streamline
process for licensure but because we
have so many statutes
um it's going to be big when you repeal
that I think that would be helpful and
could I just ask a follow-up
um I I know you were at the hearing and
I think most of the folks here their
basic message is one size doesn't fit
all so I'm hoping that
um that's reflected in what you're going
to show us in the future yeah I guess I
would disagree with that when it comes
to procedure when it comes to substance
one size does not fit all but when it
comes to procedure which is really
intended to provide for due process I
don't understand why it would be
different across the board's procedures
procedure it's just how you make a
decision it's not necessarily the
decision that you reach so I would I
would disagree with that I I know that
um you know several words believe that
they are unique in certain circumstances
I I don't but we agreed to disagree with
thank you
there seems to be two things going on
here
one is
you said this is a
repeals redundant
Pro visions of the law in other words
it's a housekeeping
but you're also changing policy
you're changing the
procedures and the policy that the that
the state
says that you're asking us to do
could you uh separate those two
so that
in some type of a report
that would explain exactly what are the
housekeeping areas and then where are
your policy changes and also
an organizational chart of the current
organization and and what it would look
like when if
this was passed and also with that
flow a flow charts or charts
that would show us the beginning and the
end of every process
how it is now and what you're asking us
to approve because there's a lot there's
this is 76 pages long and there appears
to be a lot more in here than just
housekeeping
and and quite and I come out of the out
of city government
as a city manager if I pre presented
this to a city council to throw it back
at me
because it because you're supposed to
help us to understand this
and there's not a lot of help here so
figure yes so just to be clear this is
not an oplc requested bill this bill is
a result of recommendations that were
put forth by the committee established
by Senate bill of 330 last year which we
participated in but we did not request
this bill I'm happy to provide a
crosswalk or walk you through what the
bill would do with respect to clean up I
would submit that we already have the
authority over procedures for both
licensing and for complaints the problem
is we can't have one procedure because
every Practice Act has different
statutory language in it so it is truly
Cleanup in that sense there's also been
some statutory conflicts which we've
seen with fees we've had fee sending
Authority since 2015 and we have not
been able to promulgate rules regarding
fees because the board practice acts
have pertained that and as those have
been amended they've superseded our
statutes
any type of oplc legislation is going to
be large when it's clean up just because
of the sheer number of statutory
Provisions we have and we certainly have
debated Nana piecemeal do we not do it
piecemeal I think the recommendation out
of SB 330 subcommittee
um which of course was bipartisan in
nature was that this was the way to
attack this particular cleanup Bill
there are two other bills that were
recommended by that subcommittee one was
concerns the Quorum requirements allows
boards to meet remotely we like that
idea because I think that would increase
participation and the other has to do
with the funding mechanism so to
representative infantine's Point earlier
we do need a better process for
involving the boards with with fee
setting Authority and that bill is
intended to make sure that we are
providing them with allocation
budgets and engaging more of a
conversation but when you have two
regulatory bodies that have the same
Authority it it doesn't work and what
we've seen is that on that those issues
for the members of the committee who are
new
the study committee that the director is
referring to is available online in our
statutory and chaptered study committees
section look at Senate Bill 330 laws of
2022 and I will tell you that it's
almost as thick as the bill but it's got
a complete transcript of those meetings
questions that were asked and their
final report so I think you might find
that helpful in referencing some of the
changes that are suggested
and representative I'm happy to sit down
with you at any time and walk you
through it or provide you with any sort
of documentation that that that does a
crosswalk
um at any time wasn't intending to not
be helpful but I wanted to give you the
broader picture of the history of this
bill
Madam chair if you don't mind I think um
we wanted to address another point
good morning uh thank you madam chair
for letting me speak Douglas solster
general counsel of the oplc uh director
Courtney doesn't like to say my last
name she finds it intimidating that's
true
I actually do too thank you uh
um one of the things we heard a lot
about on Wednesday we had a lot of
testimony from psychology we had a lot
of testimony from mental health after
the fact we had some conversations uh
with repetition with Dr Warner
um
and it caused me to go back and take a
second look at the language and I think
there are some valid points
um as they pertain to psychology and
mental health and yesterday I began
unfortunately I wasn't able to finish my
goal was to have some language to show
people today
um I'll finish it up as soon as I can
and and distribute it as soon as I can
but we are actually taking a crack at
amending the language in this bill to
build in some of those extra protections
that I do think are there with good
reason for psychology and mental health
and and you know investigating further I
see some of the concern they have
and what specifically concerns would
they would be addressed in your
Amendment uh some of the concerns would
be around uh who gets eyes on the
records how they're approached but also
above and beyond that there's a certain
level I think at Psychology and mental
health where
um there's a vulnerability in
potentially the people affected by a
licensee and so
what what we're also incorporating is a
requirement for oplc investigators to go
in and approach the board before we
address some of the individuals who may
not have been named or may have been
named but aren't aware not the actual
complainant themselves and sort of
building in those extra layers of
protection and getting the subject
matter experts to weigh in at an
additional level before investigations
proceed and so I'm taking the language I
did a I I reviewed the language that's
currently in law in both psychology and
mental health practice acts the language
except for citations is pretty much
verbatim it's word for word but I did a
line by line comparison to make sure
that before I proceeded with amending
the bill and I'm incorporating a lot of
that language into the investigative
piece in 655 so that it will show up in
310. now I know Dr Warner this morning
proposed an amendment to 329
and I haven't had a chance to review
that in detail but I'll look at what she
proposed and I'll and I'll see what I
can do with that as well
um of course collaboratively but I just
wanted to make the subcommittee aware
that based on testimony based on
conversations we are making some
yes
thank you um
I am sure that you are aware from the
hearing the other day also there were a
few representatives of different boards
real estate and so forth who said that
they were unaware that these changes
were being suggested my large concern is
that you have so many boards and
commissions under you that people that
were unaware of this that we haven't
heard from yet may have concerns that
aren't being brought forward also
so I can speak to that representative so
as you probably know this was a
confidential bill so we saw it obviously
um when it was released on the 20th we
do provide weekly updates regarding
um the calendar we also provided a list
of all of the lsrs asked the boards to
go through and identify ones that they
were interested in having us track on
their behalf we had preliminarily
identified some bills but we need their
guidance as well
and when this bill came out the next
board chair meeting that I have and I
have them on a monthly basis I verbally
told them about it
but again only five chairs go so you
know that's part of the issue but
um you know it's always a timing problem
with legislative process for boards
because it moves so quickly and they
only meet once a month so I do feel that
we notified them as soon as we were able
to notify them and
um you know to the extent that boards
are able to take a position where you
know we're working collaboratively with
them on that is what I would offer I
think that it's it's tough for the
boards to to participate because of the
nature of their work
thank you I appreciate that and I also
appreciate that this was not an impetus
of of you or your department
um and I know the bill came out quite
late in the process even so thank you
Mr romancore is that you coming towards
good
good morning Madam chair my name is
Stephen reinkort I'm a licensed
electrician in the state of New
Hampshire also the executive director of
the electrical contractors Business
Association and we spoke on the bill the
other day and just had some concerns
just reiterating some of the things that
have been brought forward as we
understand that uh Lindsay has a very
tough job trying to manage both sides of
this and find a happy medium we think
she's doing her best and we try to
support the best we can but we do have
some concerns especially with the
Privacy part but
kind of what was just discussed most
recently is I think Communications is
the problem
all right and and again I know Lindsay's
been out of town blah blah but we talked
about
she talked about getting this to the
boards our board met Tuesday and I
brought this to the attention of our
board it wasn't on the agenda it wasn't
there
you know the boy didn't know anything
about it so
well she's got a lot going on we still
have to work on that because how does
the board not find out about it in a
meeting a day before at least if it was
confidential which I just found out I
didn't realize you know we saw it a
little earlier but
um so with a lot of these things
communication the board doesn't know
what's going on we're finding out about
these things afterwards we hear about
this legislation we try to track it we
have a lobbyist and trying to keep on
top of it is the amount of changes that
has happened to the oplc
is incredible I mean it's just over the
last couple of years
for instance we found out about our
licenses are going to be going to a
two-year renewal we're one of the few
that do three-year renewals and I
understand why it's going to it's a
biennium budget it's much easier to
figure out stuff of that but you know I
don't think there's been any
notification sent out yet or told or
even you know ahead of time because as
licensees we've been doing three year
renewals for many years now electricians
are a little bit habitual we get the
paperwork whether it's online or not we
fill it out we send it in we think it's
good for three years again
it has to be some better Communications
with all of it the participation of the
boards
I think as much as we want to find a
procedural process that's even
they're not this as Mr infantine spoke
you know they're not all the same it
should be handled the same and if they
did take these and they're trying to
find one procedural process then they
didn't repeal these and make them all
the same as you stated there's got to be
some policy changes because not everyone
was the same right we've heard that
already so there's no way that they took
what tried to make everything even and
kept it
what it was and I just think we should
look at that a little bit more
we had some concerns as far as the
Privacy like
um the definition of allegations
complaints and investigations I think is
important
um I had spoke about a situation I had
and I just want to make sure I make that
clear it was long before the oplc was
even organized so it wasn't anything
that happened during this Administration
or the oplc but you know that a
complaint to an allegation is to
investigation somebody calls and files a
complaint because they're just mad at me
or they haven't been they're not paying
their bill and they want me to go back
and finish and now I've got a complaint
against my and it's in the file
things like what happens if that
complaint is found to be I'm found not
guilty what happens to that paperwork
and that does it stay in the oplc it
really shouldn't if you weren't found
guilty
and it was somebody just you know having
a little bit of payback or something so
who has access to all of this
information if it goes through the
investigative Bureau um I believe Mike
was here yesterday and then maybe
there's only certain people who should
have access as I mentioned before
when we were aboard by itself we had one
or two administrative people so at best
maybe two or three people might have
access to this information
I don't know the total amount of
employees at oplc and I don't know the
exact structure of it but I would hope
that we would look at that and make sure
that we're confining that to as limited
amount of people as possible if there's
an investigation department that takes
care of the allegations and stuff then
every admin in the office does intend to
have access to all of this information
you know the they're struggling to get
employees employees are changing there's
constantly new people in there so it's
just a lot of information that is open
to people seeing and going through
um
on page 12.
if you look at
I think it is lying
17.
um it talks about appeals in the appeals
to the Supreme Court one of the things
that we had as an electricians board is
we could appeal to the State Building
Code review Boyd we did that because
let's face it if I lose my decision from
the electricians board to take it to the
Supreme Court is not going to be
financially
feasible it gave us an opportunity as
blue collar workers to try to get some
sort of appeal and actually there was
one that went in front of the board that
went to the State Building court and was
overturned so I would hope that we could
look at maybe one other step before The
Supreme Court if there was appeals even
if it's a jury of legislators or
something like that I think that that's
it makes it very difficult well I
understand from a legality standpoint
it's usually how it works
sometimes it's not fair isn't fair
because you can't afford it is really
what it comes down to
um
also the um there seems to be two
page five
it speaks about it on the uh
line nine roughly it the non-lapsing
fund yes and seems to be two of them I
guess wanted some clarification on pay
on line 33 it talks about the ones
um I'm sorry
um for for the
there's one for professional licensure
um it has to do with on the professional
side there's one for the health side yes
no I am 15 I'm sorry
and
in paragraph three under that if you go
further down on line 26 at the last line
he says the money's in his fund shall be
continuing to property to the office I
just wonder if we get some clarification
whereas the yellow ones show the funds
going to back to the um general fund on
the first dedicated fund
on line 13. so I was just wondering what
the difference was if they're not 125 or
they are if we're all going to be or not
and how that affects the overall budget
and fee structure so maybe we could I'm
sure miss Courtney could answer that
question
um
also
there's
on page eight
line six
and this is just I'm just trying to give
you some examples of that this bill
needs a little bit of work we're not
necessarily against it we know it has to
be some procedure but it talks about
that if if you go back to page seven at
the bottom it talks about allegations
misconduct what they what um
they can do and it shows that on line
four says to carry out investigations
the executive director is authorized to
a retain qualified experts B conduct
inspections a place of Business and
Professional regulated under the office
all right I'm a small company I have a
home in home office I don't really think
the oplc should be able to come in and
investigate my home
I think there should be some guidelines
on that whether it's a commercial site
or something or whatever but I mean
there's a point again we were giving
quite a bit of legality to the oplc and
when we look at this
Lindsay's not always going to be the
director and everybody that in place
isn't always going to be there we've
been through this what changes with
Department of Safety we were under there
so we're trying to look broad not just
right here we're not we don't have any
issues she's been very good helping us
out working together but you got to look
at this as
are we covering everything so when
things change it's no thing there's no
issue
um trying to make sure that the boards
don't lose the control they have and I
and I I spoke about this to a few people
yesterday
how do we find some warning that allows
them to other boards have control but to
a point where if they're not cooperating
that the executive director can move
forward
I don't know how to word that I'm not a
lawyer but I think that would be very
helpful because most of the boards
that's their concern they're losing
their Authority it's all going to the
OPC like representative bentine stated
they're just jurors
you know I mean the content and subject
matter of any experts we would like to
clear that up as well so that for boys
that have inspectors that it states that
those you are used first before hiring
and everything else because they're
licensed they know it's the laws are the
codes are it's very important that that
gets addressed as well
so there's you know there's a the three
sections or three different divisions
with some some
close warding would be much better but I
understand that makes it difficult for
the executive director as well
um balancing the political and
administrative part from Justice
standpoint as you said is is very
difficult but I hope the committee will
work towards that goal and I will end at
that
thank you your testimony was respectful
my name is Laura Cooley I'm representing
myself I just want to support that last
idea he put forward that the executive
director can intervene when there is a
problem we have no root course against
boards that are not acting properly who
lie in public testimony there's no
recourse and people are hurt by this so
I would like to support this idea that
when a board is not Cooperative somebody
anyone else
yes
good morning my name is Kimberly
Kirkland and I'm a lawyer in Manchester
New Hampshire and for 15 years I was a
tenured faculty member at the law school
here in Concord and I just wanted to
address the issue you raised Madam chair
about the balance that's being attempted
to be struck with this litigation
um I I think what gets under the various
boards skin and the public skin is this
idea of procedure and having taught the
course in law school that's caused
called civil procedure for 15 years at
the Devils lawyers as well because
although procedure seems like it's just
rules about the steps we go through to
get something decided it's absolutely
integral to doing Justice you you can't
provide Justice for the licensed members
of all of these boards and for the
people making complaints unless there
are fair known consistently applied
procedures
and those procedures do affect outcomes
if the procedures are all over the place
if they're inconsistently applied if
people don't understand what they are
you're not going to get just outcomes
from the system and so I think this bill
is really trying to ensure that the
procedures are clear accessible and
consistently applied and that will work
to the advantage of both the licensees
and to the people making complaints and
it will also be beneficial to the oplc
which has to deal with 55 or 54
different sets of procedural rules which
is a nightmare
so I think it's important from that
respect I also say that although I
understand people are saying my my
specialty my substance area is different
and requires different procedures in the
legal system we've been able to create
procedures which decide disputes in a
vast array of subject areas so for
instance within civil law you have the
rules of civil procedure and their state
rules and federal rules but New
Hampshire for instance has rules of
civil procedure that will govern the
adjudication of a contract dispute a
construction claim a real estate
disputes medical malpractice claims any
kind of some subject matter you can
think of will be decided under the same
set of procedural rules so they have to
be carefully thought out with all of
those different substance substantive
areas in mind but you can create a
single set of procedural rules that can
cover a wide variety of different
substantive areas the other thing that I
see this bill doing that I think is
really important to the just resolution
of the disputes I'm I'm focusing on the
disciplinary function that these boards
serve is the division of the
investigative function the prosecutorial
function from the adjudicative function
I think you run into problems in terms
of bias when the people who are
investigating and Prosecuting are also
adjudicating and when the people who are
investigating and Prosecuting are
members of the same Market
as the people who are being investigated
or prosecuted
um I think we all have a tendency to you
know want to give the benefit of the
doubt to the people within our community
and profession we all know New Hampshire
is an incredibly small state we know
each other well and I'll tell you that
the lawyers have struggled with this as
well lawyers are not licensed by
any board from the executive branch
we're licensed by the New Hampshire
Supreme Court but in
2004 the New Hampshire Supreme Court
introduced a new system for lawyer
discipline because there were perceived
problems with having volunteer lawyers
who made up the professional conduct
committees which are the equivalent of
the the boards we're talking about here
trying to investigate prosecute and
adjudicate claim claims against lawyers
and a decision was made to create an
attorney discipline office where there
would be a professional investigator and
prosecutor who would bring matters to
the professional conduct committee made
up of a mix of lawyers and lay people
for adjudication
so I'm happy to answer any questions but
really
okay
yes yes yes yes I just I was gonna
comment thank you because I think this
is helpful
in general yes so so when a complaint is
made obviously somebody comes in feeling
that they've been wronged but they're we
don't take their word for it and there
is some investigation that needs to
happen in the Civil system you would
have a lawyer representing both sides
and they would each be given an
opportunity to explore what information
do you have what information do I have
let's exchange that information so we
both understand what the world of of
facts are that this has to be decided
from and that's what the investigator
would do here for these boards the
investigator from the oplc and it would
be that investigator's job to be getting
information from both sides and that's a
person without a dog in the fight which
thank you to anyone else yes
representative schuette thank you I will
just ask
um you talked about the Civil process
having set rules but I would imagine
that there's a separate set of rules for
the criminal process and I think that's
part of the point that's being made here
as representative infantine pointed out
there's a vast difference between
licensed professionals construction
trades and medical trades so I I think
that's a worthy point because they each
have different parameters that they have
to meet you're absolutely right there's
a different set of rules of procedure
for criminal cases than civil cases
that's because criminal defendants have
constitutional rights that are different
than civil litigants however within the
Civil Justice System we would decide a
complaint between a homeowner and an
electrician and between a patient and a
doctor and those would both both be
decided under the rules of civil
procedure
okay can you come
could you come to this mic here and
speak that way
but
I would just ask if Ms Kirkland would
outline her vision on who would do the
investigation and prosecution I assume
the board would do the adjudication but
how would that be staffed how would that
what's the procedure do you know that
she doesn't work for oplc right so but
she's made a proposal that there would
be a split of those functions and I want
to explore that idea okay and apparently
Miss Courtney has something to say so
I'll let her thank you and you're I'm
Brad Holt thank you
thank you sorry I just thought I might
be in a better position to talk about
Staffing at the office so presently we
do have an enforcement division that has
three bureaus one is with compliance
that deals with inspections which is
more of proactive compliance ensuring
that people are proactively complying
with their requirements and then we have
an investigative Bureau which has a
chief investigator he's a he's an
attorney
and then we have our prosecutions Bureau
that has a chief prosecutor who's an
attorney they he has three prosecutors
within that Bureau within the
investigations Bureau I think we now
have eight authorized investigator
positions we also have many contracts
with subject matter experts in the form
of Consultants which includes a
physician investigator actually two
physician investigators as well as
Dental consultants and nurse Consultants
we have other consultants and we are
continuously seeking additional
Consultants when we do not have the
expertise needed what happens is a board
member will recuse themselves to provide
that subject matter expertise I
envisioned that it would continue to
operate in the same manner except that
there would be a clearer division of the
investigative function from the
adjudicative function I don't anticipate
that we would require additional
investigators we do have a sufficient
investigators at this point but of
course another part of this bill would
give us the ability to retain funds to
employ additional people as necessary
and two attorney hold's Point could you
come let's ask if I think you're going
to ask doc uh Kirkland for her
interested in that okay
thank you Miss Courtney
I did not have a vision different than
what Ms Courtney has just described I
think that's what the proposed Bill does
is it separates the investigatory and
prosecutorial functions from the
adjudicatory function
and with that two-way with the function
and I guess the composition of the
medical if you sub to me do away with
that yes I think it would I I defer to
Ms Courtney on that but I think it would
at least as an investigative and
prosecutorial unit
the personnel as well some late
Personnel but from different disciplines
and so that
knowledge base would go away unless the
staff had that or used refused board
members that's part of the piece I don't
understand
I can speak to that Madam chair if you'd
like yeah so in the bill the bill
language and again this is not an oplc
requested bill but the bill language
does propose eliminating the MRC
presently how it works is well actually
there have been some recent changes with
respect to Medical complaints because
the medical review subcommittee has had
a significant issue in the last two
years making Quorum in 2021 for example
they only met about half of the time and
it continues to be at a serious problem
which has caused a significant backlog
of medical complaints the way it used to
work
prior to the recent changes in the last
several months is that literally every
complaint whether it was the physician
gave me Jello that I didn't like or I
was sexually assaulted had to go through
the mrsc and
that creates significant problems when
you have a body that's not being met
also you don't necessarily need
expertise for the complaints that are
like
I got the wrong Jello and we do get
those so
um so previously everything was going
through the mrsc because that has
created a significant backlog we
recently worked with the Board of
Medicine to come up with a streamlined
process which does allow staff for
initial review of complaints and
malpractice filings to determine whether
they've met that legal threshold of
stating a claim and this is pretty
consistent with the Civil process you
know it's pretty routine for defense
lawyers to file motion citizens saying
that the complaint doesn't allege a base
a legal basis for the claim so we do
have at the moment attorneys and
investigators who make that initial
assessment if they determine or they
believe that it doesn't State a claim
that is reviewed by our physician
investigator if the physician
investigator agrees with that assessment
it goes to the board if the board
disagrees with that assessment then it
goes for formal investigation to the
mrsc and if the board agrees with that
assessment it gets dismissed now I can
tell you what happens at the emergency
is that the complaints sit because
they're not being investigated the MRC
has explained to us that on average each
person can only review one to two cases
Max per month and that's when they meet
and they meet on average about half the
time so if we get four you know about
400 complaints a year which includes
malpractice filings that is why we are
not getting through these cases so
I don't know that this is the
appropriate model and we're not
advocating for
you know one way or the other but what I
can tell you is that the current model
with respect to Medical complaints is
not working
um the bill as proposed would change
that again we're not taking a position
on whether that's uh whether that's the
best approach and I know representative
Pearson has a separate bill on that we'd
be happy to you know work with him to on
different procedures but I will say that
this bill does propose a change and in
my opinion any change is good at this
point because we're just at a standstill
thank you we will we'll take that into
consideration
anyone else
yes
good morning
my name is Kelly ledke I am a Master
Level alcohol and drug counselor I
testified on Wednesday on behalf of
myself but I had a board meeting
yesterday so I just want to update that
I've spoken with my board members and
they have voted to give me permission to
speak on behalf of the Alcohol and Other
Drug use professionals board so that's
one update
um I'll keep this very brief because I
did submit written testimony I went line
by line for each piece that we disagree
with and some things that we feel
neutral on I think I just want
to again say
when I left on Wednesday the word
streamline was buzzing in my head all
day right that this was about
streamlining making the process easier
but I think I'm still struggling
I guess the buzzword in my head is
collaboration there has to be
streamlining of course but there has to
be collaboration and I'm not feeling the
collaboration in this piece so what I
mean by that is I do think just as
people have testified today that the
oplc has done a wonderful job coming in
and making some great changes for us I
still think there's a lot of room to do
I just want you to make make a comment
about that sure this is not being driven
by oplc I understand okay so they they
didn't make any of the changes these are
changes that were done by
Representatives who are on this bill
right okay good
but the there are going to be changes in
the way that we do things with oplc
so this isn't this isn't a bash on
anybody this is just saying if we repeal
some of these laws it isn't going to
give us the opportunity to do the work
that we need to do and some of them
don't feel streamlined right taking away
our ability to have an advisory
committee is not streamlining anything
taking away our ability to be able to
investigate cases doesn't feel
streamlined it feels like a reduction in
our Authority as a board
so I just want to make that point again
that I think everybody can work together
this feels very extreme like this this
bill feels like it's over here we might
have been over here and I want to find
us here working together boards with
oplc to make things better for the
public in terms of Public Safety thank
you thank you and thank you for that
yes
okay does anyone else who want to speak
thank you very much I do appreciate it
uh with the small packet that I gave you
uh the second page second piece of paper
had Amendment language for concerning
cost of Investigation
there's a section uh in section one RSA
310 colon 12 sanctions to delete section
Roman 5.
and then also to add a section perhaps
section 192 or reorder repeals cost of
Investigations RSA 332 G colon 11 is
repealed
um you heard on Wednesday from Dr
Phillips about the cost of
Investigations being passed along after
somebody might be found they had a found
in complaint and they're at that point
we're getting sanctions and uh just to
point out why these are not needed and
they're overdone is that
G11 was passed about in 2016 and I did
look up and there were no boards and no
providers and no professional
associations involved in the development
of that legislation
um but number one it's unheard of to
collect these costs from the convicted
even in criminal court cases the state
and the local law enforcement does not
recover the cost of the investigation
from a convicted Criminal
number two the burden of proof for the
license hearing
is much lower than that even of Criminal
Court
in the license hearing it's clear and
convincing evidence and in the criminal
court it's beyond A Reasonable Doubt
which is a much higher standard and yet
the licensee would receive a much higher
penalty
and now that is an unlimited one in G11
it was capped at ten thousand dollars
and then in this there's no cap on it at
all number three the cost of the
investigations are already paid by the
licensees as the office is calculated
license fees to be 125 percent of the
department operating expenses they're
already been paid distributed across all
licenses making these redundant Monies
and unjustified as punitive in nature
and therefore an unwarranted violation
of the Constitution's Eighth Amendment
against cruel and unusual punishment
is there anyone else who wants to speak
on this house bill
nope okay I'm closing the public hearing
I mean the subcommittee meeting
we're going to have another one
so stay tuned it won't be next week I
can tell you that okay
and in the meantime we will take all
these considerations and discuss it
among ourselves
I have four five pages of notes here and
um
we'll have an amendment that's why it's
going to take a little bit of time so
we'll have an amendment and see how far
we get how's that
thank you so much for your time and
thank you so much for caring about the
bill
foreign